Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass, es wird Zeit, mal wieder über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer zu sprechen. Da ist so einiges passiert und es hört einfach nicht auf, spannend zu sein. Ach, was für eine schöne Liga. Jetzt gleich hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Hallo und herzlich willkommen im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass Nummer 196. Mein Name ist Max-Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf Twitter. Ich freue mich total, über die 2. Liga zu sprechen. Ist einfach eine schöne Liga. Ich muss mich da wiederholen und ich freue mich sehr, hier zwei Legenden begrüßen zu dürfen. Den einen kennt ihr vielleicht aus einem eigenen Podcast, Rasengeflüster. Auf Twitter ist er der Ed, Jens Umbreit, ich begrüße ihn sehr herzlich hier. Servus, Jens. Ja, und du übernimmst gleich meinen Servus. Ach, da ist einfach der Profi zu erkennen. Ein Chamäleon des Dialektes, der Jens. Da bin ich gespannt, was jetzt dann Florian Zenger zu mir sagt. Ihn kennt ihr von Clubfans United aus der Nürnberger Zeitung und den Nürnberger Nachrichten als EdFloh-Zenger auf Twitter und natürlich auch schon aus dem Rasenfunk.
Und wie würdest du das bewerten? Denn von außen betrachtet könnte man ja auch sehr gut argumentieren, er sollte den Aufstieg schaffen als Nachfolger von Kowcinski. Das hat er geschafft. Er soll Dresden in der Liga halten. Da ist man noch voll im Rennen mit dabei, dass man da nicht vorneweg spazieren würde im etabellen Mittelfeld. Das war ja auch allen klar.
Der Saisonstart hat vielen Menschen auch Sand in die Augen gestreut. Das muss man ganz klar so sagen. Dieser tolle Spätsommer. Deshalb sagen jetzt manche, sie hätten viel weiter umstehen müssen. Diese Liga ist brutal schwer. Wenn du am Ende 15er bist, kannst du einen dicken Haken hinter diese Saison machen und sagen, Saisonziel erreicht. Ich würde es jetzt nicht nur am Tabellenstand, sondern auch in der Spielweise festmachen. Wenn du irgendwann das Gefühl hast, dass du nicht mehr viele Tore schießt und dass der Trainer vielleicht die Mannschaft nicht mehr so erreicht, dann wirst du handeln. Aber er sagt ja selbst, das betonte er bei jeder Pressekonferenz, er und die Mannschaft sind eine feste Einheit. Er steht 100 Prozent zu der Mannschaft. Die nächsten Spiele werden es weisen. Es wird ein heißer März hier in Dresden.
Was macht er denn eigentlich in der Ansprache vor dem Spiel, wenn man in der ersten halben Stunde genau ein Tor erschießt?
Ich glaube nicht, dass er da irgendwelche Bibelferse vorliest. Aber sicherlich wird auch er das hinterfragen, dass da vielleicht irgendwas nicht so funktioniert. Wobei ich sagen muss, Hamburg ist ja momentan das Beispiel, wo ich sage, es geht doch auch im Jahr 2022. Gegen den HSV sind sie rausgekommen und haben herzerfrischenden Offensiv-Fußball gespielt. Da haben sie Hamburg gepresst, da haben sie sie unter Druck gesetzt. Da standen sie auch selbst nicht unter Druck. Und so will ich eigentlich Dynamo Dresden sehen. Und da haben sie auch das Publikum, was wenig war, aber das haben sie da an dem Abend auch mitgenommen. Und deshalb, wenn sie das Hamburg-Spiel als Blaupause nehmen, dann könnte es wie gesagt was werden. Aber er muss einfach auch wieder zum Mut zurückgewinnen, wie der Alexander Schmidt. Dann glaube ich, dass auch seine Mannschaft wieder mutiger auftreten wird.
Das Hamburg-Spiel als Blaupause nehmen. Da hast du mir mal wieder ganz der Moderationsprofi die Überleitung zum nächsten Team geliefert, über das wir sprechen wollen. Denn auch der SV Sandhausen würde gerne dieses 1 zu 1 vom Wochenende sicherlich als Blaupause nehmen. Und im Grunde hat er das aber eigentlich auch schon getan. Also wenn wir über Bilbel-Ferse bei Alexander Schmidt sprechen, da würde ich gerne wissen, was Alois Schwarz eigentlich in den letzten acht Spielen seinen Spielern so gesagt hat. Aus den letzten acht Spielen nur eine Niederlage, drei Siege, vier Unentschieden. Damit hat sich Flo Sandhausen in der Tabelle raus aus der direkten Abstiegszone hin auf den Relegationsplatz gerobbt. Und da liegt man jetzt eben. Und deswegen wird es ja auch so dramatisch für manchen Verein davor, dass jetzt manche anfangen zu punkten, wie Hannover und Fortuna, und Sandhausen jetzt schon eine ganze Weile von hinten rausschiebt. Was hat sich denn da deiner Meinung nach verändert?
Es ist irgendwie, ja, Alois Schwarz spielt Alois Schwarzigen Fußball. Und das funktioniert in dieser Tabellenzone ziemlich gut. Also wenig Ballbesitz, defensiv aber mega stabil. Also wenn man sich das anguckt, haben sie jetzt im Winter mit Dumic auch noch mal einen Verteidiger geholt, wo man sagt, boah, der gewinnt irgendwie 80 Prozent seiner Defensiv-2-Kämpfe. Und auch in der Luft ist der riesig. Also das ist halt dann doch was, wo man sagt, da hat sich dann auch der Trainerwechsel, um den Bogen zu spannen, hat sich da auch gelohnt, weil da ganz, ganz viel besser geworden ist. Also es ist so, ich habe ja Alois Schwarz in Nürnberg auch mal erleben müssen oder dürfen oder können. Und der Fußball sieht eigentlich genauso aus. 4-1, 4-1, wir stehen sicher und schauen halt, dass wir vorne irgendwie das Ding reinmurmeln. Möglichst wenig Gegentore kassieren. Das ist so das eine. Und sie haben halt dann im Winter, das ist das andere, auch ordentlich was gemacht. Sie haben Dumitsch, habe ich schon angesprochen, dann Tribol, Berko, Deville, Säufert, Kutucu, also das gleich ordentlich eingekauft im Winter, da noch mal ein bisschen was verändert. Neben Dumitsch, Tribol und Berko haben schon ordentliche Einsatzzeiten gesehen. Da merkt man eben dann auch so, sie haben auch noch mal was getan im Winter. Und dann eben, jetzt kriegen sie auch die Ergebnisse. Das jetzt gegen den HSV gut aussehen, das hat ja quasi schon Tradition. Aber an sich schon, gerade so die Stabilisierung unter Schwarz in der Defensive ist schon da, nach vorne könnte immer noch mehr gehen. Da ist man halt, man kommt ein bisschen selten in den Strafraum, hat halt testrot und das war's. Das ist schon noch was, weshalb sie auch jetzt wahrscheinlich bis zum Ende da unten drin hängen werden.
Der Testrot ist aber kein schlechter, das muss man einfach mal so sagen. Er sorgt für die Tore, die anderen Mannschaften, über die wir vielleicht auch noch reden, abgehen. Und ich sag mal, sie kommen auch mit den Umständen jetzt ganz gut klar. Sie waren ja auch ein bisschen gehandicapt, hatten dann eine längere Pause. Gerade als Karlsruhe in der Corona-Pause war, hatten sie sich ehlendelang auf das nächste Spiel vorzubereiten und haben erst eine Niederlage im Jahr 2022. Kassiert sind das sechs beste Rückrundenteam. Du hast es gerade genannt, du hast die ganzen Neuzugänge erwähnt. Wenn du acht Neuzugänge in der Winterpause hast, dann weißt du, okay, da ist in der Hinrunde was schiefgelaufen. Aber dann bist du auch eine ganz, ganz andere Mannschaft, bist unausrechenbarer für die Gegner. Und die müssen sich komplett neu und anders auf dich einstellen. Und damit hast du deine Grundstruktur geändert. Und wenn sie jetzt, das macht ja momentan den Eindruck, Heimstärke gewinnt, das wird dir an Dresden nicht eingefallen, dann sind sie auf einem guten Weg, vielleicht auch noch von dem Relegationsplatz runterzuspringen. Weil jetzt haben sie gegen Aue gewonnen, gegen Hamburg einen Punkt geholt. Ja, sie wirken sehr stabil. Sandhausen ist, was Sandhausen ist in den letzten Jahren immer wieder. Sie schaffen es irgendwie dann doch noch, die Kurve zu bekommen.
Und Platz 4 in der Auswärtstabelle ist schon wirklich, das ist schon wirklich krass. Also 18 seiner 25 Punkte hat Sandhausen auswärts geholt und ist deswegen eben punktgleich mit Hansa Rostock, die auf Rang 15 davor liegen und eben nur einen Punkt hinter Dresden, hinter Düsseldorf, drei Punkte hinter Nürnberg 96. Also das, was wir oben haben mit dem Aufstiegsrennen, das haben wir unten mit dem Rennen um den Relegationsplatz. Ich denke, das muss man so deutlich formulieren, weil, Jens, du hast es vorhin auch schon angesprochen, Ingolstadt und Aue, die haben abreißen lassen, obwohl Ingolstadt jetzt sogar Punkte sammeln konnte. Du hast aber gerade schon so einen Verweis gemacht, eine Mannschaft, die vorne Probleme hat, Tore zu schießen. Könnte es sein, dass du damit Erzgebirge Aue, unser letztes Team, gemeint hast, über das wir sprechen wollen?
Ja, natürlich. Ich weiß nicht, von welcher Serie Aue und Ingolstadt träumen in den verbleibenden Elfspielen, zehn Punkte wettzumachen. Das müsste ja eine Serie eines Aufsteigers werden. Ich kann es mir in der Liga bei den beiden Mannschaften ganz, ganz schwer vorstellen. In Aue wird mittlerweile offen über das Thema Abstieg gesprochen, wie man damit vielleicht umgehen sollte. Dass man sich dann langsam darauf vorbereitet, wenn man so zwischen den Zeilen bei Martin Mennel liest. Natürlich sagen sie noch nicht, wir sind abgestiegen. Das sind sie auch rein rechnerisch nicht. Aber wenn man sich die letzten Spiele anschaut, ich habe mir die Partie gegen Holstein Kiel angeschaut, dann sind das ganz klare Kennzeichen eines Absteigers. Du liegst 0 zu 2 hinten, spielst mit 10 Mann, holst dann innerhalb von 5 Minuten diesen Rückstand auf, machst das 2 zu 2 und in der 90. Minute sagt irgendjemand Ding Dong. Ihr kassiert ja jetzt noch das Gegentor 2 zu 3. Und du gehst wieder als Verlierer vom Platz und fragst dich, was sollen wir denn sonst noch machen? Die Fehler liegen zum größten Teil im Saisonstart mit dem Trainer. Das war eine Fehlentscheidung. Das geben sie mittlerweile auch unumwundend zu. Man hat viele erfahrene Spieler oder gute Spieler abgegeben. Mit Breitkreuz, Krüger, Rizzuto und mit dem von mir erwähnten Pascal Testroth. Testroth war ein ganz bitterer Abgang für Erzgebirge Auer, weil der nicht hätte sein müssen. Der Kader ist schlecht zusammengestellt, es ist kaum diese Wismut DNA vorhanden, die sie in den letzten Jahren immer so stark gemacht hat. Und Mark Hänsel ist natürlich auch noch ein Trainer bzw. ein Teamchef, der so seinen Weg sucht. Der kommt sehr, sehr viel über die Motivation, steht dort immer mit der kurzen Hose. Aber natürlich, wenn der auch keinen Erfolg hat, dann wird es natürlich auch für ihn schwierig, das immer wieder seinen Spielern zu erklären. Das ist, wie wenn ich zum Diätberater gehe und ich nehme dann nach dessen Empfehlungen trotzdem nicht ab. Also von daher hat auch er ein ganz, ganz schwieriges Amt. Und die Winterneuzugänge, die haben er nicht so zugelangt wie andere Vereine, wie z.B. Sandhausen oder Düsseldorf, George, Owoso oder Lang. Lang ist nur Perspektive, haben eben auch nicht so richtig funktioniert. Owoso, würde ich mit Abstrichen sagen, der spielt und der macht seine Sache auch ganz solide. Aber bei Erzgebirger Aue kann ich mir beim besten Willen nicht vorstellen, wie das noch zum Klassenhalt gereichen soll.
Meine Notiz, die ich für die Sendung gemacht habe, war einfach nur als erstes Steigt-ab-Punkt.
Warum denn das?
Gegen alter Dinge, die du gerade gesagt hast, Jens.
Also um das, was du gesagt hast, Jens, auch aufzugreifen, der Kader ist auch unrund zusammengestellt. Also wenn man sich das mal anguckt, du hast…
Ich habe verstanden, du hast gesagt, dieses Ausrufezeichen steigt ab, also steigt endlich ab.
Nein, nein, es war keine Aua-Partie. Nein, keine Aufforderung. Es war eine Aussage. Ich greife auch gleich nochmal zurück. Also bei Mitrushkin, es war nur ein 0 zu 0, nicht, dass ich wieder wütende Twitter-Meldungen von Dresden-Fans bekomme, weil ich ihm was zuschreibe, was er nicht getan hat. Das andere 0-0 war noch Broll.
Genau, aber jetzt der unrunde Kader von…
Genau, weil du hast nämlich, wenn du dir das anguckst, bei den Einsatzzeiten und so weiter, du kommst halt auf, interessanterweise, du kommst auf knapp 40 Prozent der Einsatzzeiten für die Spieler, die 23 oder jünger sind, und du kommst auf 40 Prozent der Einsatzzeiten für Spieler, die 30 sind oder älter. Und du hast halt dieses Mittelfeld nicht. Und man spricht ja in der Leistungsdiagnostik ganz oft davon, dass so zwischen 24 und 29 das Peak Age ist. Also da, wo das von den Positionen her natürlich immer noch ein bisschen zu unterschiedlichen Innenverteidiger und Torwart haben andere Leistungsspitzen als ein Außenstürmer. Aber du hast halt wenige Spieler in diesem Mittelkorridor zwischen 24 und 29. Da haben sie mit Gay jetzt noch einen abgegeben. Aber gut, das ist jetzt vielleicht auch gar nicht so tragisch. Aber du hast in diesem Korridor eigentlich mit Strauß und mit Abstrichen Barilla eigentlich nur zwei Spieler, die wirklich viel spielen. Und ansonsten hast du viele junge und viele alte. Und dazwischen eigentlich quasi ganz wenig. Und dieses Unrunde ist halt auch problematisch für einen Kader, wenn du bei den Spielern mit der Leistungshoch-Zusammensetzung so wenige hast. Der Kader sieht für die Zukunft gar nicht schlecht aus, finde ich. Genau, aber fürs Jetzt halt einfach nicht ausgegoren, weil du halt noch viel auf die älteren Spieler verlassen musst. Gleichzeitig aber die Jungen schon relativ viel übernehmen müssen. Und das ist dann halt schwierig.
Definitiv. Und Florian Ballers zum Beispiel, der erfahrener Abwehrspieler, ist verletzt die ganze Zeit schon. Und weil du gerade gesagt hast, Geh, da muss ich ja drängen, du hast ja schon zwei Spiele abgegeben, die du erst im Sommer geholt hast. Er ist schon wieder abgegeben. Da weißt du ja ganz genau, dass da irgendwas nicht zusammengepasst hat bei der Kader-Zusammenstellung. Aber das Grundübel ist einzig und allein da zu suchen, dass du den falschen Trainer im letzten Sommer geholt hast mit Schipilevski, wo alle gesagt haben, entweder es funktioniert 1a, damals wie mit Domenico Tedesco, oder es wird ein Desaster. Es ist Letzteres geworden.
Das tut einem dann schon ein bisschen leid, da so deutlich den Start zu brechen, aber da sprechen die Ergebnisse eine deutliche Sprache. Aber gut, für die Zukunft ist man ja ganz gut aufgestellt. Und nur um noch das einzurahmen und auch ein bisschen deine Arbeit zu würdigen, Flo, was du gesagt hast mit diesem Mittelbau, mit diesen Spielern zwischen 24 und 29 Jahren, da haben wir eben sehr, sehr wenige Baue. 27 Prozent der Spielzeit, der Einsatzminuten hat diese Alterskohorte gemacht. Der HSV ist da die radikalste Mannschaft. Die haben nämlich 39 Prozent U23 und 61 Prozent in genau dieser Kohorte zwischen 24 und 29. Jeder, der in Mathematik so halbwegs mitgekommen ist, der weiß, oh, U30, da kommen wir auf 0,0 Prozent. Richtig krass, wie das beim HSV aufgetan ist.
Wir haben im ganzen Kader nur einen Spieler über 30, das ist Tom Mikkel. Und das ist, ich glaube, der dritte Torwart. Also das ist ganz, ganz auffällig. Wo es auch relativ auffällig ist, ist St. Pauli. Die sind bei 70 Prozent in diesem Mittelbau. Da könnte man vielleicht auch ein bisschen erklären, warum die jetzt gerade so gut funktionieren, weil die halt viele Spieler haben, die auf ihrem Leistungshoch sind. Also es ist natürlich zu kurz gegriffen, das einfach zu sagen, ja, ich kaufe jetzt einfach nur 24- bis 29-Jährige und dann funktioniert das. Aber es ist halt schon auffällig, dass das bei denen dann auch so ist, dass die sehr viel auf diese Spieler setzen. Und dann gibt es eben die anderen Entwürfe. Dresden ist, um den Bogen noch zu spannen, bei den U23 Minuten sogar erster mit 40,7 Prozent. Wobei da, also muss man immer sagen, U23 heißt halt, du machst einen Stichtag. Und das ist halt bei mir dann in den Aufzeichnungen der 1. Neunte. Da sind dann auch ein paar Spieler dabei, die jetzt 24 geworden sind, die da mit dazu zählen. Aber man kann ja nicht, das ist ja wie bei den Turnieren. Bei den Turnieren, da spielen ja U21-Europameisterschaften, spielen ja U23-Jährige auch mit.
Eben, eben. Aber ich sehe schon, du hast große Angst davor, bei Twitter Reaktionen zu bekommen, wenn du das jetzt hier nochmal erklärst. Ich glaube aber, das ist ja auch alles erst mal nur Zahlenspielerei, aber es ist halt interessant, diese Unterschiede zu sehen. Auch eben dann am anderen Ende der Skala. Sandhausen, die eigentlich kaum nennenswerte U23-Spiele haben, und das machen alles komplett. 67 Prozent in der Alterskorte, 24, 29. Und der Rest sind die U30-Spiele. Das ist so der gegensätzliche HSV. Der HSV macht es nur mit Jungen. Und Sandhausen macht es mit Jungen plus Alten. Also, ist eine interessante Spielerei. Und wirft dann auch noch mal ein besonderes Licht auf den Saisonverlauf auch. Weil man da eben sieht, vielleicht hat die eine oder andere Katerstruktur eine andere Resilienz gegenüber Rückschlägen als die vergleichbaren Mannschaften. Ohne das über bewerten zu wollen. Ihr beiden, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Das hat ganz großen Spaß gemacht. Ich glaube, man hat es der Sendung auch angehört. Ich bedanke mich sehr herzlich. Und ich möchte noch mal eine ausgesprochene Höhrempfehlung für das Rasengeflüster aussprechen. Ich bedanke mich bei Jens Umbreit. Er ist auch der Edjens Umbreit auf Twitter. Folgt ihm dort zahlreich. Jens, danke dir, dass du dir Zeit genommen hast für den Rasenfunk.
Max, das hat großen Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank, dass ich dabei sein durfte. Wir haben mal ein Rückspiel, ne? Rasengeflüster höre ich dich demnächst auch mal.
Ja, das machen wir auch. Du musst mir nur noch ein Thema darüber haben, über das wir dann sprechen. Am besten eins, über das ich auch sprechen kann. Zur Not schicke ich einfach auch so viele Grafiken rüber, wie es Flo Zenger gemacht hat. Vom Clubfans United, von der Nürnberger Zeitung, im KDEP-Podcast, könnt ihr ihn auch hören. Kann ich auch sehr empfehlen für alle, die beim Club tiefer einsteigen wollen. At flo-zenger auf Twitter, da könnt ihr alle kritiklos werden. Freut es sich schon drauf. Flo, danke dir für deine Zeit und für deine Expertise. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke ich wie immer nicht nur für eure Aufmerksamkeit, sondern auch für euren Support. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-, paywall- und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und auch unsere Gäste bekommen davon ein kleines Honorar. rasenfunk.de/supporterscluboderkiosk.rasenfunk.de da könnt ihr uns unterstützen. Ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Und jetzt vielleicht wegen dieses Aufrufes tun. Habt eine gute Zeit, bleibt gesund. Und dann bis hoffentlich bald wieder hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.